all right so welcome to this stream on
manning's twitch channel thanks so much
for joining us my name is boris
passgiver and i'm the author of pandas
in action which is set to be released
sometime early next year probably around
april or maybe may
so over the course of the next hour i'm
going to be showing you uh basically
working through a sample data set using
pandas and the topic of the hour will be
working with text data so manipulating
text in all kinds of formats whether it
be uppercasing it lowercasing it
splitting it removing characters adding
characters anything that you will ever
want to do with text we're going to
practice doing that with a sample data
set this is actually a data set and a
combination of code samples that is
copied directly from a chapter in the
book so if you like what you see feel
free to check out the book pandas in
action through manning's meep program
and you'll have access to basically all
the code that i'm going to write today
all right so if you're unfamiliar with
pandas pandas is a data analysis library
built on top of the python programming
language it was released publicly a
little over a decade ago i believe in
2009 and it's really exploded over the
last couple of years in the field of
data science and data analytics so
python now has a huge ecosystem of data
science tools uh that incorporate all
kinds of complex disciplines statistics
machine learning natural language
processing etc but no matter what domain
or field you're working with you're
going to have to manipulate data or
contort it in some way shape or form and
pandas is sort of the ecosystem or the
epicenter rather of that ecosystem in
the python data science community so
it's a general all-purpose data analysis
toolkit so anything that you can do in a
graphical spreadsheet application like
excel or google sheets you can also do
in pandas of course the advantage of
using a programming language is you gain
the benefits of things like automation
programming languages are really good at
repetition
um you gain repeatability
you gain the advantages of being able to
use your code across
multiple files repeat them
in a in a coding environment such as
this one which we're staring at right
now on the screen this is jupiter
notebook
you also have the ability to walk
through step by step the logic that you
used to solve a problem so unlike an
excel spreadsheet where you just get the
final result here you can actually see
how an analyst reached their conclusion
rather than just their final numbers so
whether it be telling the story of data
or automating it
or even just you know exploring a new
technical domain growing your expertise
because it never hurts to learn to
program because it can help you in so
many different aspects of your life and
your efficiency
pandas is a really great jumping point
it's a really great tool to learn if you
are an excel analyst
and you're looking to pick up the uh the
next cool thing if you will
so what i want to do in this next hour
of course is just walk you through a
data set show you how you can do some
common text based operations um and
we'll take it from there so we are in
this environment called the jupiter
notebook and the first thing i need to
do here is actually import my pandas
library so you of course need to have
this set up on your computer including
pandas we're not going to spend time on
that tonight because it might take a
while to set it up but of course all
that is covered in in the book and if uh
if you're not
interested in the book you can always
check out the pandas documentation as
well for a complete installation guide
so i'll begin by importing my pandas
library
and usually it's assigned the alias pd
and at the top level of this library you
can think of it almost like the lobby of
the library kind of the entrance to it
we have a whole bunch of available
functions for reading a file into our
program so there's a function here
called read csv
and again if you're unfamiliar with the
word function it works the exact same
way as it does in excel it's just a
procedure it's some kind of operation
that we can tell the library to do for
us so in this case i'm literally saying
pandas read the csv for me so in the
exact same directory where i have this
jupyter notebook i have a sample csv
file that i'm going to use for this
tutorial and it is called chicago
food inspections dot csv
and for now i'm just going to execute
the cell so we can preview what it looks
like this was copied i believe directly
from the city of chicago's
government's website so it's a list of
restaurants or food institutions
throughout the city of chicago we have
the name right here on the left and we
also have the risk that was assigned to
it based on a food inspector's analysis
so obviously restaurants have all kinds
of risk problems like rats or unclean
you know utensils or anything like that
so this is the actual public data that's
available so if you're curious about
finding out which restaurants or which
chains have the most violations things
like that you can find those kinds of
stories in a data set like this and
immediately upon importing we can we can
see that there's already some kind of
text issues here right so for example
these um
names in the left-hand column are all in
uppercase and some here we can see are
all in lowercase
the risk column doesn't appear to be too
bad but it's kind of capturing a lot of
different information for example you
might just be interested in getting the
number of the risk like one or two or
three so a question might be how do we
extract just that numeric component from
this column things like that so all
these kinds of questions will be we'll
be talking about very shortly so what
we're seeing here uh to the human eye of
course is basically a table it's a
combination of rows and columns much
like you'd work with in excel but in
pandas this type of data structure is
called a data frame pretty simple a data
frame is just the equivalent of a table
it's a combination of rows and columns
the column is the observation or sorry
the variable the kind of the column name
is the description of what is being
stored in that column and then each row
represents one record right so the name
uh for the first restaurant is the
marriott marquis chicago and the value
for the risk column is risk one and the
same
logic applies for all the records in the
data frame at the bottom here you can
see we have a hundred and fifty three
thousand rows and two columns in this
data frame so what i'm going to do is
save this to a variable i'm going to
save it to a variable called inspections
and basically that just allows me to
reuse the data frame later in this
notebook and i'm going to use a method
here on a data frame called head a
method is just a function that we can
call or invoke upon a data frame and
what the head method does is just show
show us the first five rows so rather
than outputting the entire uh data frame
i'm just going to take a look at the
first five rows just so i have a point
of reference as we proceed
all right so let's first focus on the
name column on the left let's take a
look at some of the manipulations we can
do on it so the first thing i'm going to
do is to actually just extract that
column target it so i'm going to do
inspections which is my data frame and i
can access a single column through
square brackets and in here i can
provide a string with the column name
that i want to access in this case the
name of my column is actually name
so i'm going to write that out and this
is going to return to me another type of
object in pandas called a series
a series is a one-dimensional labeled
array the simple simplest way i can
describe it is as a single column while
a data frame is a two-dimensional data
structure meaning there's
more than one point of reference that is
needed to extract any given value uh so
for example if i was targeting jet's
pizza i would need to know both the row
and the column number in order to get to
this value because i need two points of
reference uh it is a two dimensional
data frame or two-dimensional data
structure in comparison the series which
we see right here is a one-dimensional
data structure because you only need one
point of reference to extract any value
from it so for example if i wanted to
get to the value room 1520 i only need
one point of reference which is this
number to the left here
if you're curious by the way about these
numbers on the left this is what's
called the index and essentially it's
just assigning each row a place and line
starting from zero so the very first row
is assigned position zero the next one
is assigned position one so on and so
forth to the end
and so each row
is assigned kind of its own unique
identifier by which we can access it so
the index doesn't have to be numeric
this is just a default that pandas
relies upon because we haven't given it
any kind of identifiers by which we
should use
to
locate or find each row so it just says
since you're not going to give me a
custom set of identifiers i'm just going
to assume that you want these rows
ordered sequentially and i'm going to
start the count at zero and give you
that information here on the left all
right
so
it may not be super apparent right now
but there's additional problems that are
starting to emerge from this column of
data or from this series that we weren't
quite seeing when we were looking at it
right here in the big picture so notice
we also have white space if i highlight
right here with my mouse you can see
there's additional white space
characters to the right of chicago and
the same rules apply by the way we can't
see it to uh the beginning of text as
well as to many other rows in the in the
uh series so we have white space the
beginning and white space at the end
so let's first talk about how we can
remove that so on any series object like
this one we have an attribute an
attribute is almost like a property it's
just something you can access on the
given data structure it's a
characteristic or detail that may
sometimes expose other nested objects or
data structures that we can deal with so
the syntax is going to be dot str
and if i just output this result you can
see it's a nested object
on our series called string methods and
it's on this object that we can call all
kinds of methods that will manipulate
the series all right we'll take a look
at how to do that in just a moment for
now i want to do a quick review of some
of these string manipulation operations
in just vanilla python so for example if
i have a sample word i'm just going to
create a word variable here and assign
it to a word like cheesecake and what
i'm also going to do is add some white
space at the beginning
and the end of this word just so we have
something to work with
here's our word
there are a
bunch of methods related to removing
white space that we can utilize first up
we have the r strip method on a string
in python that is short for right strip
and it strips or removes white space
from the right side of the string so if
we take a look at this output and we
compare it to the one above here you can
see in my original uh word string there
is white space to the right of
cheesecake here it's removed if i want
to do the same thing to the left side
there is a complementary strip method
called l
makes sense right l for left left strip
that removes the white space on the left
side of the string so if you compare it
right here and this output right here
you can see the left hand white space
has been removed
if you want to target both
sides simultaneously there is a method
called
strip by itself no l or r to strip by
itself
so you can see right now we're going to
get cheesecake and all of the white
space has been removed so
if we want to use any of these string
methods they're all going to be
available but instead of calling them on
a single string like we're doing right
here we obviously need to call them on
every single value
within our pandas series object so we
just we want to tell pandas take this
string marriott marquis chicago call
strip on that then do the same thing for
jet's pizza and do the same thing for
room 1520 all the way through
the 150 000 rows in this
data frame or series so on this str
object you simply invoke another method
and it's going to be the same familiar
python methods that we see above so for
example if i want to remove the white
space at the beginning of each string or
the left side i can call l strip on this
nested str object on the series and
we're going to get a brand new series
with all the white space from the
beginning removed
i may be able to highlight it but i
assure you it's going to be removed same
rules apply if i want to remove it from
the right side instead of invoking the
l-strip method i can simply invoke the
r-strip method
you can see right here the white space
is removed
and probably what i want in this
scenario of course is to remove all of
them from both sides so i can call the
general strip method
and that's going to give me the series
that i want with all of the
white space from both sides beginning
and end removed so what this is going to
give me is a brand new series meaning my
original one in my data frame has not
been affected i still have the data as
it came in from the csv so if i want to
make this operation permanent i simply
need to reassign this new series to my
original series so what i'm going to do
is use an equal sign here in programming
the right side is evaluated first so i'm
going to grab the new series generated
on the right hand side with all the
white space removed and i'm going to
reassign it back to its original slot
the name column in my inspections data
frame and if i take a look at my
inspections data frame afterwards
all of the white space has been removed
in fact
i can even combine
traditional python iteration protocols
with what i did above to ensure that
every single column has its white space
removed so what i can do for example is
get a list of all of my data frames
columns
so here we have the columns of name and
risk it's available as this columns
attribute on my inspections data frame
object and what i can do is use
something like a traditional python for
loop so for each column
in this list that i see above
i want to basically perform this logic
right here i'm going to copy it and put
it here but of course rather than
writing to my name column i want to
write to whatever column it is that i
happen to be dynamically iterating over
in the current iteration which is going
to be represented by my column for
variable right here and if i replace it
on both sides of the equal sign
and run this
now i'm going to ensure that every
column in my data frame has had its
white space removed
okay so next up let's take a look at
casing it's going to be pretty much the
same thing we've been doing earlier
we're going to be accessing the str
attribute on our panda series and we're
going to be calling some kind of method
on it to manipulate the values within
that series so
first up let's talk about lowering
meaning lowercasing all of our data so
once again i'm going to target my name
column
and let's say i want to lowercase all of
the characters across all of these
strings so once again dot str the python
method that you traditionally call on a
string is called lower it's the exact
same logic here except we're using it on
the str
attribute or more specifically the
object that that attribute exposes so
right here
we're going to get a
series object with all of the
strings in lowercase format there is a
complementary upper method which is
going to uppercase the letters i believe
towards the end of our
series if i take a look at the end of it
with the tail method
you can see we have a couple that are in
all lowercase or at least have some
letters in lowercase so i'm just going
to call the upper
method right here on this small series
of five values just so you can see the
result you are of course welcome to call
it on the entire series as a whole but
right here dot str.upper
and you can see all of the
letters are going to be in all uppercase
so this is all up this is all uppercase
right here and this is of course all
lowercase all right there's a couple
other complementary ones that can prove
pretty helpful especially if we take a
look at what we're doing here so here's
my original column again nothing has
changed
what i think would be best here of
course is to capitalize the first letter
of every word right that's the way i
would traditionally expect to see a
restaurant name listed so python does
have a capitalize method
but it actually capitalizes only the
first letter of every string so this one
will give us one result but it's not
necessarily what we want you can see the
m in marriott right here is capitalized
but the m and marquis and the ca in
chicago are not so if you actually want
to capitalize the first letter of
every word and every word of course is
separated by a space
there is an automatic method available
called title which does just that
what title is going to do is capitalize
the first letter of each word now it's
not perfect for example when it looks at
jet's pizza it thinks that the
semicolon or sorry the apostrophe after
the t
is indicative of a separation and thus
it thinks the s right here should be
capitalized so it's not perfect but you
can see for most of the results it does
exactly what we wanted it to do which is
to capitalize the first letter
of every of every subsequent word we can
also see it it does the same thing with
the slash which gives us a capital b in
baskin-robbins when it was originally a
lowercase b so you can see it does a
pretty good job with slashes with
apostrophes with spaces
but it isn't perfect
all right so those are those are some
quick manipulations as far as casing
goes we saw upper lower capitalize tidal
and we also explored the strip family of
methods which removes white space all
right next up let's talk a little bit
about string slicing
so let's take a look at my inspections
data frame again here is a preview of
the first five rows
this time around i want to target my
other column which is the risk column
so i'll extract it again with square
brackets take a look at the first five
rows and here's what it looks like so
ultimately where i want to get to is
extracting let's say the number or maybe
the
risk level like high medium low from
this string and there's many different
ways to do it if you're familiar with
regular expressions that's a specific
field of programming where you use
basically symbols to indicate certain
characters so for example you can tell
python to look for a combination of any
three digits in a row followed by a
comma followed by the letter r right and
you can get pretty advanced with the
algorithms that use to search you can
say at least this number of characters
or
this exact number of digits or exactly
two or more occurrences of the letter z
you can get pretty granular but for now
i'm just going to use very simple
techniques the kind you might use in
excel we're going to dive a little bit
into regular expressions towards the end
of this hour but i just want to show you
how you might solve it if you weren't
familiar with those more advanced
programming concepts
so first up let's take a look at how
many
total rows we have in our data frame
again we can pass our data frame into
python's built-in
lend function we can see we have a
hundred and fifty three 000 rows well
what if i want to first find out how
many
counts there are of each risk in the
risk column in other words i want to
know how many risk ones there are and
how many risks three there are and risk
twos and maybe there's others that are
missing
one really easy way to do that is to
take my column
and call a method on it called value
counts
what value counts is going to do is give
me
that number
of counts for each unique value so it
turns out there's four unique values in
my risk column risk one risk two risk
three and a special one called all which
means the restaurant actually had all of
the risks mentioned above so those are
the worst violators imaginable
there's actually another hidden value
that's not present here but i can show
it to you by applying a specific
parameter or in other words an argument
or input to this method called drop an a
i wouldn't worry too much about this now
as far as the syntax but you're going to
see an additional
value appear here called n-a-n and n-a-n
is panda's internal designation for a
missing value or in other words an
absent value something that is not
present so what this means is in our 153
000 rows there's going to be 66 rows
where there actually isn't a value in
the risk column so in the original csv
there was just simply nothing there for
that row and pandas needed to place
something so that it can construct our
data frame for us so it places this nan
place holder to represent the idea of
nothingness or nullness or the absence
of value so before we proceed i want to
make sure we get rid of that because if
we don't know the risk then we really
can't do anything with that column right
let's say for the purposes of our
business logic we're going to remove it
entirely
and then just to make it easier to
extract a number from each of these
values for example i want to get the
number one the number two number three
i'm going to also change the all right
here to be risk four so i'm creating
some kind of consistency in how each one
of my strings begins so that makes it a
lot easier to extract the number that
will that exists within each string okay
so the first thing i'm going to do as i
mentioned is i'm going to remove
the nan values from my wrist column so
on my data frame i have a method called
drop n a that drops the n a n or the
absent values it accepts a parameter
called subset which specifies the
columns in which i want to look and i'm
going to look within the risk column
and if i preview this we're not going to
necessarily see the results but rest
assured what pandas has done is removed
all the rows from my data frame
where the risk column had a missing
value so this gives me a brand new data
frame my original one is not overwritten
yet so what i want to do is provide a
special parameter that is going to make
this operation permanent and that is a
parameter called in place equals true
again i'm kind of skipping over some of
these additional parameters that are not
specifically related to
text parsing and working with text data
just because it would make this stream
go a lot longer than just an hour but
all of these topics are covered in
greater detail uh throughout the book so
i've taken care of removing my null
values or my missing values the next
thing i want to do is to replace the
occurrences of this all string with a
risk 4. so what i'm going to do is call
a method on my data frame called replace
there's a parameter here called to
replace that represents what i'm looking
for i'm looking for the string all and
right now i'm going to be looking for it
only in my or sorry across the entire
data frame rather than only in the risk
column but i think that's okay for now
just for the purposes of this example so
what do i want to replace my value of
all with i want to replace it with a new
value of
risk four
and just to keep it consistent with our
other ones where there's a space and a
parenthesis and a classification i'm
going to call this classification
extreme
and once again this is going to give me
a
brand new data frame we don't see any
risks for uh right here but that's to be
expected because there's only 19 of them
in our 153 000 road data frame but
somewhere in here where they do occur i
have replaced them so this is basically
the
equivalent of an excel
find and replace operation so i want to
make this operation permanent so just
like in the method call above i'm going
to add a parameter called in place
equals true and that's just going to
ensure that we
make that operation permanent so now if
i copy this code from above and
re-execute it we can see our all
value has been replaced with risk 4 and
all of our null values have been removed
all right so now let's talk a little bit
about slicing or in other words
extracting the the right risk number
from each one of these
values in our column
so this is very similar to something
like a left function in excel or a right
or a mid we can basically start
extracting from the beginning of a
string from the end of a string from the
middle of the string
whichever way you want to attack it
so in python string
character counts start at zero which
means in each of these strings the
letter r occupies position zero the i
occupies position one the s is two the k
is three the space is four and the
number itself is five so we wanna start
at index position five when we start our
extraction
so what i'm going to do here is once
again target my risk column here's a
reminder of what it looks like and we're
once again going to target my str
attribute and on this object i have a
method called slice
so slice accepts two arguments there's
actually a variety of different syntaxes
to do this but if you prefer the
argument approach the first argument is
where we're starting from
in this case we're starting from index
position five and the
second argument is where we're ending
and that is um exclusive which means
we're going to go up to that position
but not actually include it so i'm just
going to put the value 6 here
so what this means is start at 5 start
at the character that's
in exposition five which is actually the
sixth character then go up to index
position six but don't include it so
this is equivalent to saying just get me
the character at index position five and
if i do this
you're gonna see we've extracted the
number from each one of our risks so
right here you can see
if i output this
series above or at least the first five
rows we can see risk one two three one
one and right here we have one two three
one one
and the alternate syntax for this is
using python's list slicing syntax if
you're familiar with that it looks like
this
five colon six and that's gonna give me
the uh exact same result let's see it's
not working here
let's see what else i did wrong here
[Music]
maybe they've removed that syntax since
all right i guess i was a little
mistaken here so in that case we'll
stick with just the method that we have
right here
all right
let's see what else we can do we can
also provide
negative values here if we want to move
uh to a position relative to its end
of a string so let me give you an
example just with a basic python string
if i have a string like programmer
and i want to slice from three to
negative one
that's going to pull from index position
three which is zero one two three that's
gonna pull from the g
all the way up to
index position negative one which is the
last
character in my string in that case it's
going to be the r but remember the
second argument is going to be exclusive
which means we're going to go up to it
but not actually include it so this is
going to go inclusively from g
all the way to the e before the last
character which is the r so we're going
to get gram
like so all right and we can apply this
to something um
like our wrist column so once again if
we take a look at what it looks like
let's see i don't want the number
but i want the actual classification
like high or medium or low this problem
is a little bit trickier right because
the length of each classification is
different it's four characters in high
it's six in medium it's three and low so
it's a little harder to specify one
number that fits all of them but
if we use the syntax from above it
actually is not super difficult
so what i can do
is once again take my wrist column
call the slice method
i'm going to start at index position
eight which is actually the first
character after my parentheses so it's
going to be the h
here in high or the m and medium that is
consistent no matter which one we have
because it's always going to be risk
followed by a space a number a space in
the parenthesis and then my word so each
word or each classification is always
going to start at position 8 but it's
the length of it that is different here
and what i want to say is go from there
up until the very last character in the
string which for all of them is going to
be a parenthesis and once again the last
character is not going to be included so
this means go up to it but not actually
include it in the final string
so no matter whether we're dealing with
the word high or medium or low they're
all going to start at
position 8 or index position 8 in their
respective strings we're going to pull
from that character all the way up until
but not including the last character in
the string
and that's going to allow us to pull out
just the classification by itself
all right
so that is a little bit about slicing
there's obviously a lot of difference in
tactical options here when you want to
pull out from left from right from the
middle include exclude etc but hopefully
this has given you a big picture
overview of just what is possible with
pandas there are of course more examples
in the book
next up let's move on to boolean
methods
so a boolean of course is a value that
is either true or false and it's used to
express uh some condition of truthiness
there's just some relationships that are
either or right like on or off enabled
or disabled true or false it's just one
or the other like a switch so for
example
if i were to use something like python's
built in
in operator that checks for the
inclusion of a substring in another
string so for example if i want to see
if the word pizza is found in a string
like jet's pizza
the answer's true right it's not a
number uh it's not a string it's a
statement of fact it's either true or
false that pizza is in jet's pizza and
if i search for example is the string
tuna found in jet's pizza that of course
is going to give us false and that's all
that a boolean is either true or false
yes or no
so we can use some
methods on our string or dots str object
to return series of booleans for us and
we can then use those buoyant series to
filter our data frame so for example
what if i wanted to take my
list of restaurants in chicago and i
wanted to find the ones whose name
includes the word pizza i don't care
whether pizza is at the very beginning
or at the very end or in the middle just
any restaurant that has the word pizza
in the title all right so this requires
us to combine a couple different ideas
first up this search is always case
sensitive so we can't simply search for
something like pizza
because our pizza can be spelled like
this or it can be spelled like this or
it can be spelled like this who knows
how this data is stored so the first
thing we need to do is to normalize the
data which basically means make it
consistent right we need to make
everything either consistently all
lowercase or consistently all uppercase
so that we can search for only one
variant of the string pizza with a
special you know casing of characters so
what i propose we do here is first use
my lower method to give me a series with
all the characters in lowercase and now
that there's that consistency in here i
can invoke a different method to search
for the presence of a substring and this
one is called contains now it's
important that whenever you're combining
multiple string methods together you
can't just simply call the next one like
so
because what this lower method is
actually returning to us is a brand new
series and on any series as we see right
here at the beginning we first have to
access its str attribute to get access
to this nested object which does the
actual string manipulation so the first
thing i need to do here is to once again
access dot str on this brand new return
series and on that
object i want to return invoke a method
called contains
contains checks for the presence of a
value
or a substring in every one of the
series values what do i want to search
for the string of pizza
so i'm going to get a boolean series
right so we haven't extracted these rows
yet but we have a series where a false
indicates that that row does not have
pizza in its name and a true indicates
that it does so just as a reminder of
what we're dealing with here here are
the first five rows of the name column
you can see the second row index one is
called jet's pizza so right here we're
getting a true for that
all right
so in order to filter in pandas i need
to keep this series of booleans i need
to preserve it so i'm going to save it
to a variable called has pizza
so has pizza is a boolean series
it's a series of booleans where a true
indicates that a row has pizza in its
title what i want to do is extract just
the rows that have a value of true in
this column
of the 153 000 rows give me the ones for
which the index position here has a
value of true
the way we do that
is we simply put
my data frame and then we provide it the
boolean series
has pizza and what pandas is going to do
is use the common index positions to
identify which rows could be kept so in
has pizza if row one right here has a
value of true then it's going to keep
row number one from inspections and so
now what we're going to get
is
all of the companies that have the word
pizza somewhere in their name you can
see right here jet's pizza is at the
very end right here nary's grill and
pizza pizza's at the very beginning
maybe somewhere else pizza is at the
very
middle
all cases are covered here all right
now if you're searching for something
different uh for example not just the
inclusion of a substring but its
specific presence at the beginning or
the end of a string there are also
complementary methods for that so for
example let's find all of the
restaurants here that start with the
word tacos so what i'm going to do here
is follow the exact same protocol i'm
going to start by getting my name
series
i'm going to lower
every value in this series so now
they're all in lower case and here i'm
going to once again access dot str
and this method is called starts with
so while contains is going to search for
the presence of a substring anywhere
starts with is going to search for it
only at the beginning of a string so
right here i'm going to search for
the word tacos at the very beginning of
a value
so when i get this boolean series i get
a bunch of falses for the first five
rows and the last five rows that's
totally fine because we have 150 000
more in between and there are some
truths in there so as always i'm going
to
save this to a variable i'm going to
call it starts with tacos
and once again below i provide my data
frame a pair of square brackets and my
boolean series
and now we're going to get just the
restaurants that start with the word
tacos all right same rules apply if i
want to get it from the end so right
here
inspections name
is my column let's lowercase all of the
characters and let's look for the ones
that end with the word tacos so we
explored the method contains earlier the
starts with method a moment ago this new
method is called ends with it returns a
boolean true if your series value ends
with the argument you pass in here in
this case tacos so i'm going to save
this boolean series to a
variable called ends with tacos i'm once
again going to provide my data frame
square brackets ends with tacos
and now we're going to get only the
restaurants in this list that have a
value in the name column that ends with
tacos right so tacos must be at the very
end of the string
okay so finally let's end the stream
with a discussion on splitting strings
this is another common thing you may
want to do in a graphical spreadsheet
software application like
excel so for this one i have a brand new
data set and it is found in a csv file
called customers.csv
i'm just going to import it right here
it's pretty simple once again we have
two columns we have the name of a
customer and we have their address all
right and many times we're going to have
situations like this where there are
actually multiple pieces of data hiding
within one column so for example maybe
we want not the full name of a person
but rather their first name and their
last name in individual columns or for
an address maybe we want the street and
the city and let's say the state and zip
code in separate columns as well so we
need to split a value based on the
presence of some kind of character or
delimiter for example in a name that
character
maybe the space the space is what splits
up the first name and the last name or
in an address it may be the presence of
a comma that splits it right and we need
to identify what that is and then we can
communicate that to pandas
and pandas will split it accordingly so
let's begin by assigning this to a
variable so i'm going to assign it to
one called customers
once again it is a two column pandas
data frame
and let me remind you first of how this
works in a
plain python example so if i have a
variable called phone number and i
assign it to a fake phone number like
555-123-4567
[Music]
i mentioned i can split a string based
on the presence of a given character so
if i wanted to split this into three
sections separated by the hyphens or the
dashes i can call a method on a string
called split
and i provided an argument of the
character that i want to split by so in
this case of course it's going to be the
hyphen
and what python is going to give me back
is actually going to be a list which is
a different type of data structure it's
one that stores multiple elements in
sequential order and here you can see it
has found all of the occurrences of the
hyphen it's removed the hyphen entirely
and it's basically split up the original
string into a list of three separate
strings based on where that uh
identifier or that delimiter occurred
we're going to do the exact same thing
here with pandas but we're going to
apply it to an entire column
so
as always we begin by targeting a
specific column in this case i'll target
my name
column and let's say i want to split
this by
the
presence of a space so once again we
know all of our string operations are
found on dot str so on this one i'm
going to pass in or invoke the split
method
i have to pass this method the argument
of what i want to split by this time
around is going to be a single space and
what i'm going to get actually
is going to be a series of python lists
so a series can actually store a wide
variety of data types you can store
obviously integers floating point values
strings booleans well it turns out it
can also store python lists now there
are some problems here
which is that some of our names have
things like the three right here at the
end or maybe they have a junior or a
senior so the problem is that some of
these lists are two elements long while
some of them may be three or more so
maybe what i want to do here is limit
the total number of splits that i'm
going to do i may say for example split
it at a space but only do it once
don't do it anything any any times more
than that right because i don't want to
end up with something like michael and
then vincent and three i really just
want to end up with michael as my first
value and vincent three as my second one
and that kind of consistency across the
lengths of all of these nested lists
makes it a lot easier to do operations
with them whenever you're working with
data types that are consistent in that
manner it's usually uh
less likely that you're going to run
into a bug
so there's a parameter i can provide
here called n and it's just short for
number and it specifies the max number
of splits so if i want to just do one
split
you'll notice in this scenario we're
going to limit it to just one split at
the first space so frank and manning is
going to be the exact same as before
same thing goes for elizabeth johnson
however when we get to a value like
michael vincent iii
we're going to only split it once and
you can see the first value in the list
is michael and the second value is vince
to the third and it doesn't matter if
there are four spaces throughout the
string the
pandas library is only going to
split it the first time it sees a space
all right
so now how do i get
uh a given value out of out of these
lists right what if i only want each
person's first name because i want to
for example assign it to a new column or
a new series well for that there is a
method called
get i'm once again going to invoke it on
the resulting series that i get back
from my split method and get is actually
going to take the index position
that it should extract it should extract
from each list so my first name is the
very first element in each one of these
nested lists and the first element in
python in a list always has index
position zero so here i'm going to get
index position zero from each list that
we get back from my split method
so now we're going to get the
first name of each person
which is the first element from each
nested list
if i want the last name i can of course
provide
number one here
that'll work
or alternatively
this is a a similar idea to the one we
saw earlier with slicing i can actually
provide a value of negative one
and that's going to proceed relative to
the end of the list so negative one
means get me the very last element
from each list it doesn't matter whether
the list has two elements or three or
five in this case we've ensured a
consistent number of two but this syntax
will get me the exact same result it's
going to get me the last element in each
nested list which is equivalent to
getting
the last name or the element at index
position one so there are many times
multiple syntactical options for
accomplishing the same result
all right let me go back to the original
thing we saw right here
which is a
series of python lists there is an
additional parameter that i can provide
to my
split method called expand and this one
actually expects a boolean value so i'm
going to provide a value of true and
what it's going to do is expand the list
into a pandas data frame
so right here
rather than storing it in a python list
i'm going to create a brand new data
frame with two new columns one storing
the first
element the one before the first space
because we're still limiting to only one
split and the second column is going to
store the
substring occurring after the encounter
of the first space so basically the
exact same thing we saw earlier with the
list it's just now expanded to be a data
frame and obviously because pandas does
not know what columns what column names
we want to grant in this data frame it
just defaults to numbering them
numerically the exact same way it does
the rows right here there are of course
ways that we can very easily
overwrite
existing columns uh if we want in fact
let's see if we can try this so what i'm
going to do here is this
i'm going to move this a bit to the
right i'm going to say that in my
customers original data frame i want to
add not just one column but two so i'm
going to provide square brackets and a
list
of the values first name and last name
and that's designating two columns that
i'm going to add and the two columns
that i want to add are going to be equal
to the two columns that i have generated
right here
so if i execute that and it works
you can see we've now extracted
the
uh contents of the name column
into two separate columns first name and
last name if we want to go ahead and
remove that name column that's totally
possible we can use python's built-in dl
keyword or delete there's also a method
you can call in pandas as well as always
multiple ways to solve the same problem
but for now
i'm going to delete customers targeting
the name column
and if i take a look at customers
you can see
that we have
removed the name column
entirely
all right same rules apply for any other
split so for example here's one more
example
if i want to target my address column
and i want to split all of these strings
based on the presence of a comma once
again dot str.split
providing the
string that i want to look for or in
other words the identifier by which
pandas is going to split a string so in
this case i can provide a comma which is
a good starting point but you'll notice
actually that it's going to include the
space after each comma as well so a
slightly more clever trick here is to
actually split by
a substring of two characters which is a
comma and a space
every time panda sees a comma and then a
space that's what it's going to use as
its splitting point and that's just
going to ensure that we don't have any
extra white space
lingering around at the beginning or end
of our split strings so here we go we've
split it based on the presence of a
comma we can provide something like the
expand
parameter with a value of true and here
we have a brand new data frame you can
see we've split it by street name city
state and zip code it really was as as
easy as that and then of course we can
choose which columns we want to keep
choose which which ones we want to
remove
etc all of that is possible with pens
that's really all i wanted to show you
in tonight's stream i know it was a
quick whirlwind tour of running through
all of these different functionalities
that we can do with text
in pandas whether it be changing the
casing lower casing upper casing fixing
capital letters removing white space not
replacing characters splitting um
there's all kinds of functionalities and
we've only really scratched the surface
so hopefully it wasn't too crazy or too
hectic i know for people who are brand
new to this um there's a lot of syntax
to explore you're also simultaneously
learning a programming language in this
case python sort of simultaneously so it
can be a difficult journey but i hope it
at a bare minimum that it's given you a
sense of what is possible and that's the
most important thing here that you have
a sense of what you can do with pandas
the syntax and the understanding and the
configuration will come with practice
and with time all right trust me on that
so with that i do want to again remind
you if you're curious about learning
more about what pandas can do for you
you can pick up pandas in action it's
available on manning's la
meep program which is its early release
program you can then get the book in its
early format provide feedback and
helpful commentary to help improve it
before its publication and then you can
also pick up the type the actual
book
when it comes out you'll get the final
copy
when it is actually published all right
if you're interested in more of a visual
learning style i also have a 19 hour
pandas course available on udemy.com
it's a lot slower a lot more slowed down
with a lot more examples we have a lot
more
time in 20 or 19 hours
to cover more material than we do right
here in the hourly stream but
irrespective of which one you choose or
if you choose both i think they're both
helpful resources if you're picking up
this powerful data analysis toolkit that
continues to grow in popularity and
reach with every passing month so
hopefully this has been helpful and
beneficial for you and uh best of luck
in all of your coding endeavors see you
soon